Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une petite compilation de jeux
On commence tout de suite avec
No, birdie, no !
Donnez moi tout de suite mon Oscar.
C'est super simple, c'est une sorte de courbe
Et ouais on adore les jeux où les commandes sont compliquées !
On est accroché à une falaise !
On va mourir !
Et un putain de petit poussin jaune vient nous picorer les doigts
Et donc A,S,D,F contrôlent nos...doigts
C'est parti !
*hurlement du personnage*
*rires*
Merci abonnez vous !
Putain !
Ok faut rester appuyé
Par exemple là
AAAH ! *hurlement*
Ok il pète les doigts
Ok c'est bon là j'ai esquivé
Attends c'est super compliqué
Oui ! Oui !!
NON !
Putain !
*surjoue l'amusement*
Il met la pression ce putain de poussin pixellisé là !
*rythme d'une musique*
C'est la danse des doigts !
*beatbox*
OOOOOOH!
Regardez le métal !
Vive le métal !
*rires*
OOH !
C'était chaud !
Ah, bâtard ! il a essayé sur le même !
Putain il nous a eu..
*hurlement du personnage*
FUCK
YOOUUUU
Putain c'est génial comme principe
En fait, ces contrôles sont tellement bizarres que ton cerveau bug
Là on est très très mal, on est très très...
Oh putain à chaque fois qu'il revient sur le même il me met la pression
Putain ça y est j'ai plus qu'un doigt
Change de main !
*rires*
L'enculé !
ARRÊTE !
AAH !
C'est bon !
NOON !
Je suis dans la merde,
j'ai plus.. je.. je peux plus
*hurlement du personnage*
Putain !
Il a tout picoré !
Et d'où un petit poussin comme ça, ça mange autant de doigts mon gars?
Normalement il prend une phalange, ça y est il est gavé, il mange plus pendant deux semaines
OH LALA !
Là on est hyper doué vous allez voir il va rien pouvoir faire.
C'est ce doigt là...
Putain !
Putain
P..
*beatbox*
Petit oiseau on va te défoncer !
Sur ce beat, nul à chier !
Ok c'est reparti, c'est l'heure de la putain de vengeance mon gars
Salaud...
Salaud
OOOOH
T'y crois
Il est deg', regardez comme il est deg' le con !
Oh, il fait que les mêmes deux doigts !
Non je me suis enflammé
Putain ça m'apprendra à me moquer du petit oiseau !
C'est hyper chiant parce qu'en fait t'es comme ça quoi
T'es vraiment comme une énorme merde
AH !
AAAH !
Non, non, non...
Hé regarde on est bon là, on est bon là !
Hé là on fait un carnage mon gars c'est la position
Mais non ! Mais non !
C'est quoi ce doigt ?
Mais non... Ah mais c'est le pouce !
Non ?
Putain j'ai rien compris, allez...
*sifflement*
Voilà, si j'étais un oiseau, je serais hyper moche.
*musique*
Messieurs-dames, nous sommes maintenant sur The daily grind
C'est parti pour vivre une journée, encore plus nulle que nos journées à nous.
On appuie sur G pour se lever.
Il a le même biceps que moi !
On appuie sur B pour se brosser les dents.
C'est passionnant, c'est palpitant.
On prend la voiture, on va au travail.
On est arrivé au travail, on travaille.
C'est passionnant.
C'est le meilleur Gameplay auquel j'ai pu jouer.
On retourne chez nous en appuyant sur D.
*rires*
Le manque de respect !
On s'endort.
Oh ! +50 !
Voilà. C'est la fin du jeu c'est ça ?
*rires*
Ah ! C'est reparti pour une nouvelle journée, pardon
Je sais que vous vouliez en vous plus sur ce jeu mais..
On se bosse les dents.
Quelle surprise.
OH NON ! Il tue des gens !
En fait...
Il tue des bébés !
*rires*
C'est ça la chute du jeu putain,
ça valait le coup d'attendre 120 minutes.
D'accord,
on part là dessus...
*rires*
Je m'y attendais tellement pas !
C'est nickel !
En fait, à chaque fois que j'ai refait le jeu, ça a un tout petit peu dézoomé,
et là on a pu voir qu'il tuait des bébés, quoi.
C'est un dangereux criminel.
Et du coup après la vidéo sur la justice on sait combien d'années il va prendre hein !
Ah Ah ! Le retour du juge Squeezie !
C'est la fin du jeu.
Voilà !
C'était... hyper chiant.
*musique*
Put your hands up in the air !
On est à l'Euro 2016 du 100 mètres souris !
C'est très dur d'aller sur Twitter en faisant ça...
Le but est extrêmement simple, il faut scroller le plus vite possible.
C'est le 100 mètres scroll on va pas se mentir !
Êtes-vous prêts? Start, attention...
C'est parti !
Putain, je scroll dans le mauvais sens !
Allez, fin du game, disqualifié.
Ok je suis prêt.
I am ready.
'tain, on va tellement vite mon gars !
On est à 8 secondes
9 secondes
Attends, déjà, on est au-delà du record du monde du 100 mètres réel
C'est plus dur le 100 mètres au scroll que le 100 mètres réel mon gars, t'y crois toi?
Et t'es obligé d'y croire puisque je le dis.
Si t'y crois pas tu te désabonnes et tu TE CASSES !
*rires*
Allez...
Allez scroll !
Je suis qu'à 6 mètres ? Non c'est une blague.
C'est une blague !
Mais mec ! Attends, mais y en a pour 1000 ans !
Moi je voulais faire une vanne, je pensais que ça durait 10 secondes quoi !
Attendez... attendez... attendez...
Moi je pensais qu'on allait rigoler, qu'on allait faire ça pour s'amuser mais on est là pour gagner !
*souffle*
Tous les sportifs ont un bandana.
Sauf que moi Nike n'a pas voulu me sponsoriser.
La petite bouteille d'eau pour bien s'hydrater....
Ouais je sais j'avais plus d'eau donc j'ai pris... j'ai pris du Tropicana !
OOOOOH ! On se concentre !
Ok? on est des sportifs haut niveau.
*souffles*
Start.
C'est parti !
*musique épique*
AH !
Putain c'est douloureux !
Je sens l'acide, dans mes muscles !
J'en peux plus !
On n'est qu'à 10 mètres,
on a fait un dixième.
Putain mais autant courir dans la vraie vie mon gars,
t'as l'air moins con, et ça te fait plus les abdos
Allez, faut se fixer des objectifs pour réussir, on va dire qu'à 50 mètres on a le droit de boire un coup...
Si on est pas mort avant putain !
On se relâche pas, on se relâche pas
NON ! Mon bandana !
NON !
On perd du temps !
Sans lui je n'y arriverai pas.
C'est bon !
Ok c'est reparti.
*cris*
On a fait un tiers,
ça remonte toujours le moral,
ça fait toujours plaisir.
Hé ça brûle à force !
ça me brûle la peau !
AH, LA CAMÉRA, ELLE A PLUS DE BATTERIE EN PLUS !
Qu'est ce qui se passe dans ce
*bip*
Ils se sont moqués de nous.
*cris*
Ils vont le regretter.
Là, je vais vous le dire, là..
On va pas blaguer.
On dirait un peu... Tupac.
On dirait Tupac.
*chant*
On se reconcentre !
Allez, les paris sont lancés !
Vous mettez maintenant dans les commentaires combien de temps vous pensez que je vais mettre à faire le 100 mètres scoll.
*musique épique*
Ok !
Attends, sur le ventre, sur le ventre
ça va plus vite...
sur les côtes...
SUR LE TÉTÉ !
oh ouais
en plus ça m’excite !
Putain je commence à transpirer,
je commence à transpirer je me sens mal
AH !
AH JE FINIS À GENOUX !
Je cours sur les genoux, m'en bats les couilles !
Et si tout bêtement j'augmente la sensibilité de ma molette,
est-ce qu'on ferait pas 100 mètres en 2 secondes ?
Presque la moitié, presque la moitié.
Ne jamais perdre ses objectifs de vue,
jamais !
Ok 50 mètres, la pause d’hydratation !
Ah !
Un petit coup de synthé et on y va !
*musique*
C'est parti !
Croyez-moi, tous les sportifs de haut niveau font ça à un moment dans leur carrière
quand ils n'ont plus le courage.
Un petit coup de synthé et ça va toujours mieux !
Ah putain mais ça fait mal à force !
*cris*
Ok plus que 30 mètres, c'est les 30 derniers mètres de l'espoir.
On va y arriver,  on va y arriver, on va y arriver, on va y arriver...
NON !
C'est bon, elle a rien, je me suis affolé pour rien
Ok plus que 18 mètres !
Je sais que vous avez toujours cru en moi,
que vous avez liké la vidéo quand je vous ai dit de la liker si vous l'aimiez,
que vous vous êtes mis nus quand je vous ai demandé de vous mettre nus pour m'envoyer du courage,
que je vous ai dit de m’envoyer des photos de vous à poil pour que je puisse me masturber
*rires*
N'importe quoi j'ai jamais fait ça !
Ok les deux derniers mètres, les deux derniers mètres on donne tout, on donne tout !
OOOOOOOH !
*musique épique*
On est..?
Premier mondial !
On est 186 440ème.
Bah voilà j'ai sué, j'ai sué, j'ai scrollé...
Oh mon dieu on a un classement !
Donc on est bel et bien 180 440ème.
Et le premier il a fait combien ? 2 secondes.
Bon beh ce qui est bien, c'est qu'y a pas de tricheur dans ce classement
*rires*
*bip*
Bon beh voilà les gens c'est la fin de cette vidéo...
*claquement de doigts*
C'est plus correct.
...sur le 100 mètres scroll et deux autres jeux mais on s'en bat les couilles
parce que le 100 mètres scroll c'était trop bien.
N'hésitez pas à l'aimez si ça vous a plu, on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine...
N'hésitez pas à faire ça, sans tricher hein, parce que les deux secondes.. OUIII !
C'est honteux !
A très bientôt dans un prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé !
Portez-vous bien !
Tchao tout le monde !
PEACE !